[Musique]
une friche industrielle
transformer en océan d'ordures nous
sommes seulement une vingtaine de
kilomètres de paris à courtry en seine
et marne
juste à côté d'un espace naturel protégé
il ya du tout venant de tous les côtés
on sait des tuyaux des matériaux de
construction on voit des restes de
démolition de bâtiments on voit des
pneus de la basse et de la carrosserie
voilà du polystyrène on sait pas ce que
ça va devenir sa plus tard regarder
comment ça s'effrite de tous les côtés
la décharge sauvage s'est créé entre
l'été 2010 9 et le printemps 2020 en
plein confinement des moquettes des pots
de peinture des matelas des isolants des
tonnes de déchets déposés illégalement
un collectif de citoyens s'est constitué
habillés en rouge ils se font appeler la
brigade écologistes ils fouillent les
gravats pour retrouver les coupables
ce qu'on fait c'est effectivement essayé
trouvé des documents des numéros des
chiffres qui nous permettent de remonter
deux tracés de retrouver la traçabilité
de ces de toutes ces choses là un peu
partout tous les indices sont
photographiés dans les valises sûrement
des papiers encore qu'on peut retrouver
répertoriés et on voyait à la préfecture
parfois la brigade contact des
particuliers pour comprendre comment
leur document se sont retrouvés ici ça
vient probablement de déménagement à
dire que le déménageur s'est pas fait
chier il a pris ça et puis la décharge
est ici le pauvre mec qui la lui il y
est peut-être pour rien mais la filière
ce sont quoi des défis liés à d'artisans
des filières de déménageur qui veulent
pas aller payer la mise en décharge et
qui en fait s'en débarrassent sur le
premier rang de revenus le but de la
brigade est de constituer des preuves
pour instruire une plainte auprès du
procureur la mairie de courtry et la
communauté d'agglomération ont fait
fermer tous les accès à la décharge dans
laquelle maintenant les déchets
pourrissent et c'est bien ce qui
inquiète les défenseurs de
l'environnement donc il ya des nappes
phréatiques la de son lot va partir un
peu partout et puis en bas on va la voir
ses taux le nettoyage s'annonce
difficile nous avons contacté la
communauté d'agglomération elle n'a fixé
aucune date précise pour le déblaiement
il y aurait selon elle
8500 tonnes de déchets le coût de
l'opération devrait dépasser le million
d'euros
plus étonnant encore à vaujours en
seine-saint-denis
c'est une décharge invisible qui
intéresse la brigade écologistes sur ses
terres agricoles appartenant au parti à
la commune des camions auraient déversé
des déchets du btp avant de les enfouir
on le voit sur cette vidéo que nous nous
sommes procurés les rotations étaient
incessantes
l'un des employés d'une entreprise
voisine en a été témoin
pendant un an vous avez vu des dessins
des déchargements
20 30 40 camions par jour dans le champ
aujourd'hui il reste encore quelques
déchets visibles
ça c'est de la ferraille qu'est ce que
c'est cette ferraille ça c'est pour
faire du béton armé donc le béton armé
s'est d'ailleurs on voit on sait très
bien que c'est des déchets qui sont
issus de la construction
la hausse a rien à faire ici quoi une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
elle concerne également un autre terrain
de vos jours où s'est joué le même
scénario à seulement quelques mètres des
habitations des huissiers ont constaté
les faits photos à l'appui on distingue
ici des pneus des barres de fer au
milieu des terres déversés nous avons
rencontré le maire de vos jours qui a
été entendue dans le cadre de l' enquête
non non non je n'étais pas au courant si
j'avais été au courant j'aurais stopper
immédiatement je dirais le défoncement
de ses terres
je l' ai su qu à partir du moment que
les services de police ont ce thème
m'auditionner dans cette affaire
plusieurs mises en examen ont été
prononcées
l'une d'entre elles concerne l'ancien
directeur des services municipaux de vos
jours en 2020 en france plus d'un
million de tonnes de déchets sauvages a
échoué dans la nature